previously on TV sins
[Music]
I have to talk all of you into doing
something something I know we need to do
I don't know how to talk about it really
because the one thing this show seems to
actually be good and consistent at is
talking about things Walking Dead
character is a badass prepared for
anything an alter aware of their
environment until the plot needs them to
be incapacitated cliche after finally
getting off Hershel's farm show
continues to subliminally taunt us by
leaving a few frames of it in the
opening credits killing killing killers
so after you kill the killer and become
the killer or future killer it's
justified in killing the killers who
killed the previous killers murder logic
is hard that you know roms OMPs house
looks nice I guess Matt Foley didn't
have it so bad after all
it's saved by the water then let's just
go someplace by the water how dare you
bring your logical thoughts into this
world of chaos and faulty reasoning keep
that up Lily and they will write you off
the show without the audience even
knowing how you died make mud pies mud
shadowing vacation good idea
maybe bats wanna Barbados the bat skills
no well at least I took a swing at it
no all right coming up one of these days
dear zombie Zeus in Hackney to heaven
the first half of this episode is all
lovey-dovey teddy bears rainbows and
unicorns and Nina corns aren't even half
decayed with pieces falling off and told
Tyreese yeah I was gonna take it if you
took every episode of this show and took
out all the Walking Dead scenes where
Rick is having an internal conflict uh
battle leadership decision and
struggling with what to do morally you
might have enough left for a
feature-length film but just barely
you should be resting after the night
you asked so should you
I'm going to on my way to find an open
cell and see block until Dee gets
cleaned up no one will be seated while
Bob and Sasha discuss sleeping
arrangements and prison cleanup
schedules so you are gonna let me thank
you
nope skipper you guys gotta see this
there's something we need to talk about
it can wait
oh yeah you better come take a look at
this that doubles as an important
conversation too late for convenient
reasons The Walking Dead showed up to
play today
whoever did this I don't think that's
who killed Karen what an important
conversation delay double down via
explosion folks we may be witnessing
history today not octubre what the hell
is up with the delivery on that line can
we hear that again not Octubre what's he
say next
there's Cowell now Rick yelling so loud
himself out of his American accent is
possibly one of the greatest things ever
do one more I don't make decisions
anymore never change Rick Grimes never
change I'm not here let's let's have
that talk at least Rick's yelling might
be audible but there's no way anyone can
hear what the governor is saying at that
volume also can I even see what's going
on for all the emotional weight that the
scene is supposed to hold it kind of
loses steam when you realize everyone is
much more likely squinting at the
muffled barely audible figures in the
distance completely confused which
somewhat describes my experience
watching the show in general now that I
think about it doesn't have to go down
this way I got more people more
firepower but do you and how would you
know if you did sure a tank is
impressive but like he said blowing a
hole and the prison would serve zero
purpose considering the governor wants
to live there
so it all comes down to whether or not
Rick and the gang want to save Michonne
and Hershel and I'm sure they do but war
has casualties and shelter and a safe
haven is about as necessary as anything
in this world
the governor has very little leverage
here even though the show wants you to
think he has all of it nor maybe I'm an
[ __ ] man Hershel and Michonne have
magically cozied up to each other
considering just a few seconds ago there
are at least seven feet from each other
it's almost like they favorite shot
composition over continuity meanwhile on
Downton Abbey I'm a good shot
I could end this right now coral has a
point why wouldn't they just shoot the
governor even if they don't know that
would end this whole thing right now it
would seem like a worthy chance to take
there maybe I'm an [ __ ] no just so
you talking about Rick manic child
supposed to be strong to protect
yourselves they have guns we should have
been Stu
this episode has way too high at per
capita of children and I'm just saying I
don't tune into this to experience mr.
Rogers labor hood let's stick with the
adults Kay why does the governor make a
beeline for Hershel first when he's had
such a raging Michonne er this whole
time she's the one he once dead anyway
sure maybe Hershel is more beloved but
not enough that would make much of a
strategic difference and since when is
he level-headed in these choices anyway
what we want he's what you got Harry
this tank gunman is discount Toby
killing so hard I have expect him to
pound his chest and yell out Apes
together strong fire for all the
pointlessness that happens to fill out
most of these episodes I guess it's
worth mentioning that the show does
manage to make you love these people
deeply enough that when it decides to
sacrifice them to the plot it actually
has an impact Herschel was one of those
greats and both he and Scott Wilson will
be missed
lots and lots of shots are fired during
the opening salvo of the battle and no
one dies how is the governor's jacket
intact and clean when he clearly took a
hit on his right arm just a few seconds
ago how did Megan not turn into a zombie
and the length of time it took Lily to
walk all the way over here I would love
to see that unfold how the [ __ ] could
she find Tara or have any clue what
random safe place she goes to find and
hide out and despite the raining gunfire
and explosions these two will have space
and time enough to engage and some Tyson
Holyfield in because how would we know
how much they hated each other without
some intimate fisticuffs I would have
given at least half the sins back if
they'd given some of these random
casualties actual red shirts to wear
Daryl is now hiding behind a filing
cabinet that I'm surprised is stopping
bullets I'm not saying that thin filing
cabinet metal couldn't stop bullets I'm
just saying they are usually so weak
that I can accidentally put a pencil
through one when I push too hard while
writing
Deus Ex Michonne oka Judith is fine but
you show for even making us think you
killed off a baby and now that the
tension is released these two zombies
will just snap quietly in the background
even though Carl's jr. just shot several
consecutive rounds off about 20 feet
from them I guess that noise attract
zombies thing only matter is when the
plot needs it to huh
[Music]
then your boss is the chief executive of
Fantasyland
let's take him out back and beat it out
of it what do you want us to do I want
you to survive they got walls fences
huge trucks the land you find out life's
this game of inches so is football
because in either game life or football
the margin for error
I'll be right back I'll be right l'ainte
her that doesn't make sense
I have a tank we have a Hulk but I don't
think we have a choice we don't you do
we're not leaving
invade our space and we fall back
assimilate entire worlds come therefore
back not again the lines betrothed
yeah just keep swimming just keep
swimming just keep swimming swimming
swim